let's just talk about the world as it is
at the moment for just a little bit do
you believe on this show oh you can
curse your brains out but but what do
you mean you're you're a you don't curse
i know but yeah i do if you promise me
you'll believe that then it'll curse oh
i yes my people will bleep it yeah
my guest this week is editor-in-chief of
dailywire.com editor-at-large of
breitbart.com a syndicated columnist a
radio host and a new york times
best-selling author you want me to throw
in anything else
you got a serious resume i mean i was
doing some research on you you pretty
much do everything i felt my time yeah
it's a busy day yeah all right well i'm
i'm very happy that you're here because
i have had all of twitter basically
saying to me for about six months you've
got to talk to this guy this is the guy
who will either convert you to
conservatism or you guys are just going
to hate each other i'll turn into a
flaming bernie sanders socialist yeah
that's that's pretty much pretty sure
you're that's not the direction that's
it'll be a conservative by the end of
the conversation all right well let's
see let's territory yeah let's see what
happens but but a lot of people also
said that even even liberals that that
know of you said i don't agree with this
guy and a lot sometimes i don't even
like him but there's there's some
principle based around what he does so
that and that's pretty much my spirit of
what i do here so that's why i wanted to
have you on well thanks for having me i
got a lot of requests to come on your
show so i'm glad you invited me yeah all
right so let's get to it so first off
you are actually born in l.a and brought
up in l.a i thought there were no
conservatives in l.a what the hell are
you doing here yes my parents were were
both they voted for carter in 76 and
they were reagan republicans
and then because we're orthodox jews
religious jews tend to vote republican
and be culturally conservative and so
that's sort of the milieu in which i
grew up so yeah um yeah i became
conservative basically from from birth
i'm not i'm not a new convert right so
how is that growing up a conservative as
a kid because what's that saying you
know if you're not liberal in your
twenties you have no uh heart and if
you're not conservative and you're
thirsty you have no brain something like
that right yeah exactly how was that as
a kid i have no heart so it works out
beautifully yeah well how how is that as
a kid growing up you're conservative as
a kid it doesn't it just doesn't sound
it doesn't sound right somehow well
again growing up in religious
communities a little bit different than
growing up in a non-religious community
religious communities tend to be more
conservative and in la conservatism is
all about social issues right when it
comes to economics there's kind of the
the you'll see the people driving around
in the mercedes-benz with the bernie
sanders sticker but everybody knows
they're full of it so there's a lot of
that in beverly hills right now oh yeah
oh yeah and it's like okay you can just
drive down to cars for kids any day now
just give it away and enjoy yourself
like i don't understand why you need my
money you clearly have some of your own
so anytime but in la it's it's all a
cultural thing conservative versus
versus leftist and i like to distinguish
leftists from liberals because i don't
think they're the same thing
conservatives versus leftists in la is
very much about kind of a character
assumption if you're if you're a leftist
you're a good person if you're a
conservative that means you're an
uptight john lithgow type from footloose
you don't want anybody to dance that's
what it comes down to right so i
definitely want to dig into the
difference between liberals and leftists
with you because it's something you
focus on a lot from the right and it's
something that i've focused on a lot in
the last year from the left where do we
get to a point where
like to me at some level there should be
some sort of progressive tax it
shouldn't be necessary you know when
they talk about the one percent
the studies are sort of all over the
place but it sounds like if you earn
about 400 grand a year you're in you're
in the one percent i i'm not in the one
percent i am you're in the one percent
yeah good all right well it took me a
long time again i borrowed some money no
no all right there you go that's why i'm
in the one percent there you go these
people who represent how to take care of
their money but okay so i'm by the way
i'm proud of that fact i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna act like everybody acts
ashamed about how much money they earn
in this country i think is the only
thing that's charming about donald trump
is that i think that you should be proud
of how much money you earn in this
country because if you worked to get
there i mean i spent a lot of money to
go to law school and then i spent a lot
of time slogging in the trenches and now
i make a really good living and i work a
lot of hours to make that really good
living and my wife you know we had to
pay her entire medical education out of
pocket and she's going to be a doctor
and she's going to make a really good
living good for her good for me good for
good for anybody who earns a living in
this country that's it that's it that's
a good thing right as far as the
progressive tax no i think the
progressive tax a bunch of crap i think
that what about at some point so you get
to 10 million dollars a year that it
could be progressively you know going up
a little bit you just don't believe in
that no because i don't see why you
deserve a bigger percentage of my money
because i make more money right you the
all taxes are is a is a gangster
shakedown and so when when and that's
all they are and so we can all agree
that some gangster shakedowns are
worthwhile because we have to pay for
police but the idea that
here's the problem with any sort of
progressive tax there are three and this
is just the general problem with
progressive taxation you have three
people in a room two of them are not
bill gates and one of them is they vote
two to one that they should take half of
bill gates as well okay this is a
simplified version of american politics
yeah the ques here's my basic rule for
all legislation and all taxation
if you pass this law are you willing to
shoot the person who disobeys
because that's what the government is
the government is just a big shooting
people machine right that's what the
government does the the insult in
whether you're talking national defense
or the police there are certain laws
where you pass them and you say if you
disobey this law and if you resist me
with a gun i'm willing to shoot you so
what laws are you willing to shoot
somebody over this seems to me a pretty
good measure of am i well so for example
for taxation
yes so the question is are you willing
to shoot people who don't pay taxes if
those taxes go for the national defense
that protects us all the answer is yes
because if nobody pays that tax then
presumably everybody dies in some sort
of terrorist attack but if you're going
to ask me you know are you willing to
pay a progressive tax for whatever
stupid government bull they're pushing
today and am i willing to shoot somebody
over that no i think the purpose of the
tax is just as important as the
percentage i know people try to make the
utilities argument i don't think it's
particularly good really because to me
it seems it seems maybe not fully
because we don't own it it's not a
public utility but there's something
else going on so it's not utilities but
i would argue that the the owners of
these companies the people on the board
you know jack
zuckerberg and all these people they are
so intertwined with our politicians
right now yeah that now it actually i'm
not saying it's directly a first
amendment thing but there's something
there because it's almost collusion with
the government so i i agree and the
solution to that is to downsize the
government radically not to not to have
you know
our guy do it right you know that's it
and that's that's what i'm say that's
what i'm seeing generally is like it's a
it's our guy doing it so it's okay now
but um but yeah of course i think that
zuckerberg working closely here's the
thing
zuckerberg wouldn't be working with the
government if the government were
powerful right like if we spend a lot of
money on the government we give money to
political candidates we spend all of our
time talking about trump or hillary
because the government's powerful i
think anybody spent tons of time talking
like in 1836
about the national election i'm sure
they spent some time talking about but
it wasn't dominant the way that it is
now yeah the idea that people were just
they could the most important decision
was people not dating right destroying
their lives because who won the
presidency when it was franklin pierce
no no no nobody nobody was doing that
and part of the reason is that the
federal government just was not
particularly powerful so what do you
care what some bureaucrat in washington
dc is doing it doesn't affect you so
that really i've said this a couple
times to me that's the best argument for
small government yeah i agree which is
it wouldn't if you don't like hillary
and you don't like trump it's not well
then i should vote for more democrats or
vote for more republicans
get these idiots out of our lives
exactly exactly and that's and that's
the i think the only smart thing that
rick perry said in his presidential
campaign in 2012 is he said you want to
make washington dc insignificant in your
life i was like yeah that sounds great
to me yeah because
i remember anything else yeah exactly i
said i said i say this on college
campuses all the time on college
campuses kids are constantly thinking oh
there's so many obstacles to what i want
to do and you see in politics now trump
keeps saying there's an obstacle to what
you want to do and on the left hillary
says there's an obstacle and i'll knock
down all obstacles we're all going to
knock down all the obstacles and they
erect new obstacles right yeah and it's
in what i've always said is nobody gives
a crap about you like no one cares about
you know i'm sitting around going dave
ruben i've got to stop that guy how do i
stop dave ruth but there's a couple
people there there are there are a few
likes
that's true but but as a general matter
if you weren't even in politics if
you're just a guy right nobody would be
sitting around going how do i stop dave
rubin from becoming a successful
accountant right nobody's doing that and
except that the government does do that
actually and so if we could apply that
same sentiment to the government like
nobody it's nobody's business what you
do with your life leave me alone solve
your own problems right those those few
sentences in conjunction would solve a
lot of would solve a lot of problems
right solve your own problems get the
government out of your life nobody cares
about you except like you and your
family and your friends yeah both sides
regard quote the other as evil is it
inevitable that we will eventually
destroy each other as the result of our
differences in the concept of morality
i'll just add one little piece that i
sort of see something like this
happening that a whole bunch of us good
decent people which i actually think is
most of us are going to keep trying to
hold some sort of sane middle thing but
the inevitability of the two sides that
want to destroy each other that believe
the other side is evil is sort of
something that we can't ultimately guard
against from both i mean i think this is
right the politically driven this is
something where
the narrative of politics is strongest
and most
most useful when it is these stark terms
when you talk about good and evil this
is what motivates people right every war
speech ever given in any film is all
about how the other guys are really evil
because it's motivating
and that's going to be true in politics
also
when it gets to individuals and this is
why you talk about individuals why i
talk about individuals a lot of that
goes out the window there's a study that
i heard arthur brooks talking about
recently on a podcast where he was
talking about how
in the 1930s there was a chinese couple
that went around the united states
staying at hotels and they were never
discriminated against they went to like
250 hotels one of them turned down
service then afterward they called all
250 hotels on the phone and said we're a
chinese couple we want to stay and 240
of them so we don't serve chinese
couples meaning that when people were
actually confronted with the actual
human being that they were talking to
then they weren't willing to go follow
through on their ideological
discrimination and and their stereotypes
about the evil of chinese people then
they were just willing to treat you as
an individual and i think that's one of
the things that's been lost with the
lack of community like how many times do
you actually talk with a person who you
don't talk with every day in today's
society the answer is not very often
right on social media it's always behind
a twitter handle which means that you
can which is really more for insulting
people
or on facebook where you never see the
people but uh you know this is what
robert putnam talks about in terms of
the social fabric dissolving and bowling
alone and we don't have communal places
anymore and that's why
the people who you find who are the
friendliest contrary to in my experience
contrary to the public opinion put forth
by hollywood are people who are in
church groups right you go to a church
group these people treat you like gold
right i mean i'm an orthodox jew i walk
into a church church everyone's friendly
they're all used to each other they see
each other on a regular basis they do
things for each other
and maybe that only extends as far as
the in-group but i think that the more
often you're interacting with various
different in groups the more often
you're going to be
willing to
you know to count in somebody who
disagrees with you yeah well listen i
mean my own personal experience is and i
said in my direct message from this
morning i will give the exact same
speech that i gave at turning point usa
in front of all those conservatives i'll
give it to any progressive group if
they'll invite me yeah but i suspect
they will not make you because you are
fact-based you talk fast you you don't
care i mean you genuinely don't care
about people's feelings i i i know you
pretty well now you don't that they
don't have an immediate family yeah
maybe maybe your wife but that they
don't know how to respond to that then
because they're used to dealing in a
realm that is all about that so now you
come out and you're like no no no no
this is the way it is i'll debate you
but you're not gonna beat me just
because you happen to be gay or a woman
or whatever else it is and i think
actually now
that's a lot of the reason of your your
surge well i i think that most people at
root level don't actually want to think
of themselves as their group identity
first i think most people want to be
respected on an individual level and so
when i say in order for you to be
respected on an individual level that
means that i'm not going to respect you
on the group level right meaning i'm not
that your your group identity doesn't
mean anything to me your individual
identity means everything to me but your
group identity means nothing to me and
when i say individual identity i don't
mean how you identify you know in terms
of race or gender i mean in terms of
your thoughts are your thoughts
interesting or are they right or are
they wrong and they're either right or
they're wrong or they're interesting or
they're not and that doesn't change
based on who's saying it and if we could
all get there i think that that's what
people find appealing is that if you can
get there then you can actually have a
discussion about ideas if not then
you're just going to retreat into your
identity and there's no way for me to
have a discussion with you i mean i just
had a
talk at uconn
and one of the students got up and was
talking about abortion
and she said you know i i would never
have an abortion but you as a white
privileged male how could you talk about
abortion and i said because right is
right and wrong is wrong regardless of
whether i am a white privileged male i
mean that's the basis for western
civilization
otherwise we can't have it we can't
that's right and then what what happens
if we can't have a conversation across
groups and we just fight for dominance
that's that's exactly well that and
that's the post-modern world view is
that that's all we're doing it's like
fine but like
you're you're you're opening the door to
the radical right wingers because
they're going to come in and say okay no
problem we'll play identity politics but
i'm not losing how's that right it's
like well that isn't the way you're
supposed to play you're supposed to be
guilty it's like no sorry i'm not going
to be guilty i'm just going to be
dominant exactly this is the danger of
the the actual alt-right because what
the alt-right is it's a reactionary
identity politics movement and the left
doesn't want to acknowledge its own role
in helping to drive the the emergence of
a reaction or identity politics movement
which by the way i find despicable
because i think all identity politics
movements yeah
that's exactly what i think too yeah i
don't care i mean right or left i did a
year of shows on if the left doesn't
clean them when i was still saying i'm
on the left if we don't clean up our
house what is going to happen and look
what has happened so shifting slightly a
little bit i thought this would be
interesting is there a criticism
actually i'll start with you first on
this one is there a criticism of you
that you think is the most legit
no criticism
um
you know i i think that
the
the criticism of me that i think is
legit is one that i think is probably
common to most people which is i tend to
fall into confirmation bias which is
true for
everybody so you know i think that but
it
you know when you're in the political
realm the easiest thing to do is to find
evidence that supports your position and
cherry pick the evidence in order to
support that position uh and so if the
idea is that i tend to do that i try to
fight that but i'll acknowledge that
that's a flaw that i have uh that you
know when you're when you're invested in
a political fight that the easy that
that your easiest mode of confrontation
is to find stuff that supports what you
already think as opposed to taking in
all of the available evidence and then
shifting every point as we were talking
about before uh toward the toward the
right position uh it's because i think
it is a weakness it's something that i
that i try to fight as often as possible
and uh i try to make provision for that
so so before i ask you yours um what do
i think
what do you think hey what do you think
is wrong with ben and b
what do you think is psychologically the
best way to deal with that to be to be
aware right you're being aware of what
your issues limitations are what your
biases might be but psychologically what
it is just surround yourself with
competent people who who have their
areas of expertise that aren't yours and
to listen to them
you know and that's that's helped me
over the last 15 months because i've had
about 10 people around me five of them
are family members about five of them
are friends who are extraordinarily
competent people and they go over what
i've been doing and they don't pull any
punches this feelings thing this is
something i'd like to spring to your
defense about because the rule if you
don't have an ethic is don't hurt
anyone's feelings it's like okay but
which feelings do you mean do you mean
like this seconds feelings or do you
mean the person's well-being across a
year because lots of times when you're
having a firm discussion with someone
that upsets them in the present this
happens with children all the time is
you're
you're not taking stock of their
feelings at the moment except in so far
as you have to because you want to help
prevent them from cascading into
catastrophe for the rest of their life
it's right well i'm going to discipline
you right now i'm going to tell you why
you were wrong we're going to have a
hard conversation because if you keep
that up your life is going to be a
never-ending stream of misery well
that's not cruel
and so but because people don't
see
the ethic of iterated games let's say
something like that they say well you
just shouldn't hurt anybody's feelings
in the moment it's like
no what's so funny about the left right
the left will say that diversity is our
is our greatest benefit and then they
immediately try to wash away everything
that is diverse about how people behave
except for
biologically or amazing
at the same time they'll also say well
we should be more like countries like
sweden and norway and finland and some
of the most homogenous countries on
planet earth right i mean like yeah and
by the way there were plenty of people
there who are very worried about the
directions that their countries are
going sweet so we've got all these
lefties in america saying oh it's so
great over there and the amount of
people that we met there that are
completely uh afraid of saying anything
norway and denmark are immigration
restrictionist countries it's so funny
the left will talk about the wonders
well sweden is now right but because of
the backlash right because of the
backlash to massive islamic immigration
into sweden and the and the fracturing
of society in areas like malmo that's
why all the jews are leaving sweden and
sweden has elected a center-right
government specifically on the
immigration issue so yeah i mean to to
ignore
um
for for me
individually and collectively um
the biggest source of unhappiness for
people is pretending that reality isn't
reality when people fight reality they
lose and recognizing that reality is
reality is is necessary whether you're a
nation like sweden or whether you are an
individual who's struggling with certain
realities like people's unhappiness
springs from thinking that reality is
mutable but they are immutable
mostly you're immutable and reality is
not mutable let's just talk about the
world as it is at the moment for just a
little bit do you believe on this show
oh you can curse your brains out but but
what do you mean you're you're a you
don't curse i know but i do if you
promise me i'll believe that then i'll
curse oh i yes my people will bleep it
yeah
i've been waiting for that for a long
time shapiro because i've heard you say
[ __ ] off my guys don't have to bleep my
[ __ ] they can bleep your face yeah yeah
that's i've heard you say [ __ ] privately
and then you put your little as you know
as you know there is a bit of a gap
between public persona and in private
curse of blue streak because you know so
that's that's not that's not a great
shock but yes okay so yeah let's let's
just do it for a little bit uh
are we [ __ ] like what the hell is
going on here right now um it feels that
way i mean it really does feel as though
any common bonds that we once shared are
basically disintegrating and that you're
being pressured into mimicking the
belief that all those bonds are gone so
even if you believe that the bonds
aren't really frayed and that really we
should have some stuff in common if you
say that out loud you're part of the
system you're part of the white
supremacist system and this is
it's such dangerous stuff and as we're
sitting here very in the last few hours
there was a there was a
sort of graphic that came out from the
national museum of african american
history and culture which is a
smithsonian institute taxpayer-funded
institution by the government funded by
the government uh and it was all about
whiteness and the evil's whiteness and
among the evils of whiteness things that
we have all integrated into our lives
because of the prevailing system of
white supremacy where things like hard
work individualism
justice
time management
delayed gratification
science i'm not kidding this is all in
the document these are all these are all
things that are listed as elements of
white supremacy that must be rejected in
order to move forward into a better more
progressive world and so all the things
that you would think like yeah i feel
like we should all have this in common
like you know science this one this one
we should have in common there's a whole
movement to say no no all of these
things are outgrowths of an evil system
and that in turn is a the result of an
absolutely despicable redefinition of
the term racism for what it used to mean
in for virtually all of human history
but certainly since the 1960s to what it
means now so in the 1960s racism was
what we all think of racism as believing
in the inferiority or superiority of a
particular racial group right very easy
definition you can spot it whatever you
see it right it's not not hard it's very
easily applied definition and then
there's been an attempt in the last
several years to redefine racism to mean
any system that results in racial
inequality is itself racist and so if
you are not seeking the destruction of
that system you are complicit in racism
and in order to be anti-racism you have
to seek to destroy that system well
every system in human history has
resulted in inequality of some sort or
another because human beings have
different capacities we make different
choices if you literally you tell me
we're not all exactly the same we don't
have all the exact same thoughts and
gifts and skills you're telling me stop
being racist stop it stop it so
it's slightly different abram kenzie
specifically writes this right how to be
an anti-racist he says literally any
system that generates racial inequality
is a racist system and so therefore it's
not like you're a bad person because
you're a racist you're just a product of
the system or you're upholding the
system and in order for us to fight that
racism we have to fight the system
itself and so anything that is part of
that system anything and everything that
is of that system is tainted by racism
and must be ripped down completely and
if you are complicit in the system by by
doing things like hard work and
individualism you're an assimilationist
right this is what this is what kenzie
says and how to be an anti-racist and
robin d'angelo sort of mirrors this and
you're saying yourself wait a second are
you closing in an awful lot of doors to
black americans and minority americans
like the pathways to success in a free
system are things like hard work
individual effort you know thinking
ahead delayed gratification like this is
not unique to capitalism or the evil
american system or anything right but
also what are you saying about black
people could write this [ __ ] right i
mean you really could i mean david duke
could write the idea that whiteness is
about hard work and individual
initiative and religious adherence and
family structure right that's crap david
duke would write yeah but the
anti-racists are writing the exact same
crap and they're saying yeah but all
those things are bad right and if we
just got rid of our adherence to these
systems well then we wouldn't really
have to have standards that we hold
people to and then equality would be the
result i mean that's insanely dangerous
stuff but because the charge of racism
is the most is the most highly charged
charge you can make against somebody
it's the worst thing you can call
somebody in america and for good reason
because that is an awful thing to be
right it's an awful thing to say about
somebody it's an awful thing to be
because that is such a highly loaded
term it's so easy to cudgel people into
line all you have to do is just
acquiesce all you have to do is be the
person who cheers on the guillotines as
the guillotines chop off heads and we'll
leave you alone now we're not going to
say that you're left alone forever right
this only holds true all the time for
the next guillotine if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell